hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
may 3rd 2021 what's going on
yeah how's it going man how was your uh
how was your weekend
do you have a good one did you enjoy
yourself
i had a great one i hope you did too oh
bill oh
did did did you do a podcast today to
throw your
air quote great weekend in our faces
uh yes i did yes i did i had a great
weekend and
uh while whilst trying to control
my temper as i told you guys i'm not
angry anymore i understand why i was
angry
but i i need i need
new coping mechanisms
i swear to god if you guys saw what i
flipped out about
on on say yeah like
and both flip-outs were within um
i don't know like [ __ ] three minutes
of each other and i was doing
so [ __ ] great is what happened so we
decided to have a little pool day right
get the kids in the pool dad's making
the burgers doing all of that [ __ ] right
and i did the whole
[ __ ] thing right i took the solar top
off the [ __ ]
little splashy pool we got there right
of course it's all [ __ ] turning green
and [ __ ]
i don't know what happened right so i
gotta hose that [ __ ] thing off
the [ __ ] hose i got uh doesn't have
like i don't have one what do you call
it the nozzle thing right
so i go to my wife i'm gonna run down to
the hardware store i'm gonna get a
nozzle
and she what do you do that for i'm like
well i'm gonna get it so i can spray off
the top because it's got a bunch of
green [ __ ] on and i gotta i gotta get
rid of that and she's like
okay is that something we can do after
the kids sir
which she's right she's right but i'm
like
wanna [ __ ] go now right now now go
now right
so i and i you know what i stayed in the
pocket i go okay that's cool i'll do it
then right so go down
[ __ ] pool this green ass goddamn tarp
uh
it used to be clear now it's got these
green streaks in it they're driving me
[ __ ] crazy
and i walk over to the garden hose just
to see what's up maybe i can just put my
thumb over it or whatever and what's
funny is i pull the hose out
of the little potted plant that it was
in and i realized that
there was no place to screw it on
anyways which it just ended as a rubber
hose
this is like yet another thing the last
people's everything they [ __ ] did was
cheap so i got this [ __ ] hose just i
don't know
so i was like well [ __ ] i would have
gone to the hardware store
missed out on you know kind of
interacting with the family and all of
that and
and not i came back with this [ __ ]
nozzle
um and hey what what why
you know you got no suit to wear to your
job i would be i don't have a [ __ ]
the threads to put this [ __ ] thing on
the goddamn hose
jesus what am i trying to say
so i was like well that actually kind of
worked out i was able to spray up you
know put the thumb over
increase the pressure or whatever and i
was able to hose it off it looked good
got everything out of the way so then
everything's good but coming down
i i literally look like robert young on
father's nose best if he
had some sort of pigment issue and uh
was was dipped in [ __ ] orange number
six whatever color i am
in crayola so we're coming down right
out to the pool
and um you know we get my son you know
we get everybody ready
put the sunblock on all that type of
shirt i got my stuff i got my [ __ ]
stupid hawaiian shirt on that i
literally got in hawaii
it's a real one right it isn't i got it
at a real gift shop
in honolulu and uh
bathing suit on slathering on the
[ __ ] sunblock right i look like i'm
about ready to do some kabuki dance
i got the [ __ ] on so thick right so we
got to put my son
in the little floaty thing and as we're
putting it in the thing is just sinking
i'm like what's going on here
my wife's putting together she goes yeah
i don't understand he's sinking i go we
forgot to blow it up
it was a new one right so now we go to
take it out now there's [ __ ] water in
the thing i gotta squeeze it all out or
whatever so finally i get all the water
out of the [ __ ] thing
and i go to blow this thing up
orally right and uh nowhere's going in
i'm like what the [ __ ] there's another
one maybe this is the one try it on that
one nothing's going in
like jesus [ __ ] christ and my wife's
like man baby it's broken
we have another one upstairs so i go all
the way upstairs to go get the [ __ ]
thing
back in the house go upstairs go get the
[ __ ] thing
get it out of the box do all that i go
to blow it up that one won't
take any air and i'm just and that's
when i just snapped
the wind was open and they were down at
the pool and all of a sudden they just
heard their dad just go
[Music]
really
i had done like 5 000 [ __ ] things i
got everything out of the [ __ ] way
i'm outlining all this information for
my instrument exam that
should be coming up in the next couple
of months i have to do 10 [ __ ] pages
a day
of the driest most [ __ ] up [ __ ] i've
ever had to try to
shove into my brain ever i'm sitting
there with flashcards making these
things before everybody gets up i do 19
other things and now it's like okay
i gotta have the grill going i gotta
have all the ham my wife seasoned the
hamburger i got all of this [ __ ] going
all i could need to do
is get the kids in the [ __ ] pool get
the kids in the pool
and this [ __ ] will not so now i
have to go [ __ ]
onto youtube to try to find the right
floaty
and all of this [ __ ] right and oh i
skipped as i went to do that
i go to my son's room and i could smell
the diaper thing needed to be changed
so i pull the [ __ ] bag out and
there's no place to tear it off
and it just keeps coming out like a
musician pulling i mean just i'm a
magician pulling
the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of his mouth like
is this ever gonna end
right
and i i was just like what the f what
the [ __ ]
and then i realized it was a new one a
new style of thing
and i then i just snapped again it's
like why do they always have to try to
make it [ __ ] better
i knew how to use the other one screen
that that floated down to the [ __ ]
pool i don't know if they heard it or
not
and then i figured out like it was
different or whatever and i was like
what the [ __ ]
and rather than reading the instructions
i just
started ripping it out of the [ __ ]
thing i undid the whole thing like i was
undoing a [ __ ] parachute
and then i finally looked at it and oh
you're supposed to just rip it off and
then tie it off this is actually
probably more efficient because
then you can use more of the plastic as
a bag
so if it's if you got a really stinky
dip in there you can just decide that
okay this bag ends now
and so then i tried to repack the
[ __ ] thing
and i couldn't get it back together and
i just was like all right
and by then my wife came upstairs
oh i just come up to get my son's little
hat that's what it was
i had such blind rage in those moments i
don't even [ __ ] remember what
happened
then i apologized you know my wife's
looking at me like
how many times you can apologize i just
said listen i know that behavior is
wrong i know that behavior hurts you
i just i have 50 years of muscle memory
that this is where i go to
i should have just relaxed i should have
just looked at the instructions that
were clearly written on the inside of it
and i wouldn't have done that but i
didn't
so you know i think she appreciated that
but you know
as much as she hates that i do that you
know your woman secretly loves when
you're that in the wrong
because then they they get to they get
to [ __ ] you know
gives them all this power to just kind
of be like yeah okay
like whatever you know or maybe i'm just
blaming her because i'm embarrassed by
my behavior so
whatever we ended up going down there uh
we had a great time in the pool got some
awesome pictures
and uh the great thing if you get a
little last pool like myself
um it just wears them out it wears
everybody out so then we got him inside
i made the burgers
um you know my wife told me i thought
you were gonna make him like the guy
made him down the street
and i was like okay that's not really a
thank you is it
um you know what i should have done i
should have been like i just got up and
stormed out like she would have
instead i just went like oh yeah yeah
i'm still making them the way my mom
used to make you know your mom
makes them right the burger was always
like a giant hockey puck
right but now how you got to make it you
got to have them long and flat
with the grill turned up so they're
juicy on the inside and the edges are
crispy because those are all the [ __ ]
rage and i got to tell you they are
delicious
they are [ __ ] delicious so uh she was
just like yeah i thought you were gonna
make them that way
i was like and then i'm like like you
know compliment boy like oh but but it's
still good right
did i did i do a good job she's like no
no it's just you know i thought you
gotta
do it the other way just uh
we forgot to get chips
[Laughter]
cooking for somebody on a grill on a hot
summer day is just the thankless [ __ ]
job right
so at least this is the way this is my
version of it
so anyway we end up getting the kids
back inside
and they just go down they're just out
both of them for two hours it was great
and i was hanging out with my wife on
the couch and i fell asleep
and my wife was in heaven because all of
her kids were sleeping
including myself the [ __ ] 52 year old
[ __ ]
eight-year-old uh the maturity of a
[ __ ] eight-year-old
not even an eight-year-old it's
insulting i have the maturity of a
[ __ ] six-year-old and i'm a dr and
i'm trying to bump it up to seven
okay baby steps literally so
um and then she was able to chill
you know and watch her shows and uh we
had a great time so if i just if i just
didn't do those two things if i just
didn't do those two things
we had a perfect i had the perfect day
i had the perfect day and i i and just
me always [ __ ] it up
i was the one that suggested maybe doing
a cookout my wife you know once we get
him in the pool that's we should do some
burgers too
she was all about it she was all excited
i had her in the emotional state that
that i'm always going for
keeping her happy don't be a douche bill
and what does bill do after all this
yeah
yeah yeah [ __ ] flips out about a
floaty [ __ ] thing for a pool and a
disposable
diaper thing
i fl i yelled probably as loud as
somebody when they first discovered
they're on fire that's how loud i yelled
it's ridiculous i'm an embarrassment of
a [ __ ] human being but
whatever i got past my other [ __ ] so now
i just need to like today
today i was you know i
like today i have a zillion [ __ ]
things to do after i told you guys i was
gonna stop doing that i don't know
i said [ __ ] yes to like nine things
today i got like nine things to [ __ ]
do today and i gotta take my kid to the
park i gotta do all of this [ __ ]
get mother's day cards for all the moms
in my life all of this [ __ ]
and you know and you know i'm in the
grocery store with my beautiful daughter
and she's doing dad i want this dad i
want that
dad dad hey dad dad dad dad dad dad and
i never flipped out
never flipped up i didn't do any like
like i didn't do any like you know that
stern talk you do like honey can you
just i'm i'm trying to die
you know i didn't do any of that i just
kept muttering to myself
i have a beautiful house with a pool
beautiful kids and a beautiful wife
there's no yesterday you flipped out
over a floatie too she's like dad you're
not listening to me
just like oh
jesus but i was able to do it so that's
my new thing
okay and and you know why i was able to
do that because i
rather than thinking yesterday you have
a beautiful house and beautiful family
there's no reason to flip out over this
[ __ ]
i how it works in my brain this might
help help any other angry lunatic out
there i have to say it out loud before
it becomes a thing
if i think it then it's just in my head
and it's just a dream this is the guy i
want to be i'd literally be like
say this the next time you're gonna flip
out
over something you shouldn't be flipping
out about you don't flip out about a
four-year-old acting like a
four-year-old
in a supermarket you don't do that you
just
you just mutter you mutter that's my
thing like what was that what was that
uh
jackie gleason pins and needles needles
and pins something something something i
don't know what the [ __ ] it was he was
trying to control his temper i have one
of those now
count to ten count to ten with me that's
what i'm trying to do oh my god
i need to play drums like you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] read about right now
um all right so
last night um well let's continue on
my great weekend i um
this weekend i had my first spot
indoors at the comedy store since
march of last year i was in the
uh the main room
and uh it was [ __ ]
magical it was unfucking
believable the comedy store is going to
be so incredible
um as we gradually come back and i'm
also really excited
you know as much as all the guys that i
loved a bunch of them
have moved away you know texas jersey
[ __ ] tennessee and all of this [ __ ]
um
it's sort of this exciting time of like
who's gonna slide in and
fill those gaps because that's the thing
about the store
is every time you think like
oh man there's the end of an error
what's gonna
you know will there ever be more fun it
always
[ __ ] just people just [ __ ] step in
and it's incredible you know i always
look at it like
you know if the store survived the
passing of richard pryor i mean i think
it can pretty much survive anything
because a lot of beasts
um have flown the coop here
so i'm excited and it's also great for
me as an
old comic because i feel like it's going
to be young comics coming in and young
comics
keep old comics like me young you know
not physically obviously but like just
being around them what they talk about
and stuff informs you of what's going on
so you don't
you you stay uh what's that word uh
contemporary you know your act even
though your act is the uh like me the
act of a soon to be 53 year old man it's
still
me talking about my life but my cadence
my delivery like i swear to god dude
stand up comedy changes
just like music does and [ __ ] that was
cool
five years ago becomes corny within five
six years becomes
packy or whatever and cadences
deliveries references all of that [ __ ]
um changes i know i've said this a
zillion times but it was always
fascinating when
back in the day when i was a young comic
and i would see
some comic that i was a huge fan of in
the 80s
and they ended up getting a sitcom and
they got sucked into that world if they
didn't continue doing sick
uh stand-up when their sitcom was over
six you know someone went six seven
seasons
and in those you know five to seven
years
they would come back like yeah you know
i'm thinking of doing some stand up
before i figure out what the next thing
is for me they had all that syndication
money
and they would show up and oh my god
they were coming in there it's like it
was like you were wearing clothes
their act was like clothes that were
like brutally out of style
so um i kind of already felt that
when i went down there just on the first
night that there was um
there's gonna be all this opportunity
for like new blood to get in there
and it's gonna be [ __ ] amazing
because that place
is i don't know it's just it's in there
it's just marinated in the walls the
magic
of the whole [ __ ] thing is in there
and i went down there i was a little
tired and the second i got in that
hallway i just [ __ ] oh my god i'm
back
in this [ __ ] place that i love and
um yeah i went out
everybody killed everybody was killing
eliza was on before me she crushed and
then uh
eleanor uh kerrigan was on after me and
i had to head home you know i had to get
me and the wife some ice cream
sandwiches you know i'm trying guys i'm
trying
trying to be a [ __ ] goddamn good guy
here
not be a self-involved [ __ ] like i
have been and um
but at you know and the time it took me
to introduce her and just
walk backstage and come walk grab my
coat and come walking out she was
[ __ ] murdering murdering
one of my favorite comics and she's also
just from an era
the way she grew up i like relate to
um just latch key kid vibe
and she's got this hilarious thing she
told me one time how
she came from this big family and one of
her brothers didn't know how to fight
and i was like really and she had like
this like disappointment for him
she goes yeah i used to have to step in
and finish his fights
one of my favorite things she ever said
it wasn't even on stage i think we were
in that [ __ ] parking lot
next to the magic castle um
so anyway uh i watched the uh the f1
race today i got all excited
because when lewis hamilton won the
first one it's just like
[ __ ] man is there as any team ever gonna
get a car that can compete with mercedes
and we all know lewis is just one of the
greatest of all time
um but it's just it gets [ __ ] boring
it really gets boring i got to admit so
i
i didn't get around you know i'm busy i
didn't watch the second race and i saw
max verstappen once i was like oh [ __ ]
man that's exciting
maybe they'll go back and forth back and
forth right so i sit down today
not realizing the back and forth meant
lewis wins again today
um and i was psyched because
lewis hamilton was in second place
botox got the poll so i'm excited it's
like okay
you know if lewis is going to win every
[ __ ] race at least watch him have to
pass a few guys
instead of just getting great start
getting turn one and just win the
[ __ ] race right
so um the first
like 10 15 laps were exciting because uh
verstappen actually passed lewis
hamilton like he was standing still on
the straightaway and i was like oh my
god
he finally got the [ __ ] car and i was
flipping out
and then uh like i don't know like five
laps go by and then lewis hamilton did
this
[ __ ] unbelievable pass on the outside
of the turn
i mean the guy's jordan of a driver he's
[ __ ] unbelievable goes around the
outside
and i was like okay all right okay well
maybe they'll go back and forth they're
gonna go back and they were catching up
to botos
and um i don't know and then botos is
tires i don't know what the [ __ ]
happened he started dropping back and
then it was just louis
and max verstappen and then like 10 laps
go by like that
15 laps go by like that and i'm like ah
[ __ ] here we go again
is this race over and then i had to go
get the mother's day cards and go to the
grocery store and all that i came back i
got to knock out this podcast so i
didn't have the [ __ ] time to watch
the whole race and i was just like you
know what
i have a feeling i'm going to go i'm
going to watch this race on fast forward
i have a feeling this is what's going to
happen
lewis is going to be in first place
until he he pits
and then somebody probably max
verstappen's going to try to stay out
there and then they'll be in a lead for
a little bit
and then the big drama the race is going
to be can max pit and get out before
lewis is out on the
you know passes him and uh turned out it
was perez
i don't know how he stayed out there for
a while
until the laps like 50 to 55
and then louis was out in front and uh
he had like a four second lead it's just
it was over i saved myself a bunch of
time so
two races to one i'm really hoping um
i thought early on they said there was
something going on with max uh max's car
i don't know if it was the uh one of
those [ __ ] airfoil things there on
the front i don't know
the terminology but uh it was still fun
to uh
to watch a little bit of the race there
but i'm gonna watch the moto gp
um this afternoon which i'm telling you
guys if you want to see passing and all
of that [ __ ] there's no pit stops they
say go
they [ __ ] ride like 23 laps
full out it is [ __ ] incredible um
i imagine the race already happened at
this point but uh it comes it's actually
on
uh what is it channel 220 on directv
nbc sports or something like that they
carry it so i am
[ __ ] beyond excited to watch that
today see what happens see if mark
marquez is able to uh
return to form or slowly come back
it's very exciting so um speaking of
exciting
you know when i was whining about the
lack of color options
for the ford f-250s and i was reading
all the different colors that they had
and all of that [ __ ] well guess what
you know there's some chip that they
need to put in the engines of those cars
and they're back ordered and stuff
they're having a problem getting it i
don't know why
but fords are actually a little bit hard
to come by so um the guy i was gonna go
through said if you're gonna get this
ford f250
it's gonna be a 2022 model and i said
cool do they have any new colors and he
goes a matter of fact they do and dude
they brought back all of these
[ __ ] incredible calls listen to this
[ __ ] they got
i don't know ad gate black metallic
animator blue which they already had
then they have this atlas
blue metallic which i cannot [ __ ]
wait to see on that truck
because the velocity blue was too blue i
like the annie matter blue but i didn't
quite love it
the atlas blue metallic seems like a
nice middle ground then they got
carbonized gray
which they had then they they have a
green
a [ __ ] i love green uh then they have
gem iconic silver they had that they
brought back the
orange the [ __ ] orange
i loved it they got oxford white race
red that they had before
then check this out they got school bus
yellow which i know a lot of you guys
are like what the [ __ ]
go look up like a ford f250 from the 70s
right
that yellow and white the yellow would
be on top and the white was on the
bottom and then they had like this
really cool interior
uh stone gray metallic then they have a
vermilion
red which i think if you have like the
black blackout package with that would
be sick
and then they got like uh and then they
have another yellow
and i went from like i'm not loving
these colors
to i don't know which one i want to get
out of what everything i just mentioned
there
the blue metallic the green
i got to see green gem one of the greens
what do you just do that [ __ ] orange
oh billy redface coming down the street
to [ __ ]
orange with the blackout oh my god the
competition ormond orange like mark
wahlberg's
corvette and [ __ ] uh boogie nights
that masterpiece of a film i need to
watch that again
i gotta watch that again there's just so
many incredible
performances and i want to say that
that's the one that made
i think that's the one that made mark a
movie star
i believe which is also incredible
because he came up in music and back
then you know
now it seems people can do that because
it's because of guys like that
because back then people like no no no
you do this and this is what you
are and he was like no no [ __ ] you i'm
also doing this and then he crushed it
in that movie
and then you know the rest is history so
i gotta watch that
uh i have been going back watching all
these these movies
um from the past and one i watched last
night i've been doing this mickey rourke
you know um 1980s films
so uh you know i watched rumblefish
a couple months back i watched the poker
greenwich village
when i was out in oklahoma and then last
night with my wife
i go hey let's i go she goes what are
you doing up here i said i'm going to
watch angel heart
angel hat and she goes ugh
you're watching that movie why like i
didn't think it was that bad of a movie
she goes i [ __ ] hated that movie i
thought it stunk i just remember i saw
it i thought it stunk
right i was like wow okay
all right sorry and this is classic
like white people watching something and
black people watching something and
having a complete
i should have her on the podcast having
a completely
different like outcome
so i watched the movie and i'm watching
it and i'm really liking it i'm like
and she's watching it going this isn't
as bad as i i forget why i didn't like
this movie right
i'm watching it and watched it she's
going well they kind of have like a
diverse cast here you know they're up in
harlem you know there's a lot of black
people in this but
then they get to the point where he goes
to new orleans
and uh um what's her face there from
from uh g why do i suck with the name
lisa bonet
from the um from uh
the cosby show at that point absolutely
stunning
amazing actress and all that she's in it
right and she's down there
in new orleans and there is this scene
where she's doing this voodoo [ __ ] and
she's like [ __ ] her titties are out
she's covered in blood dancing around
with the chicken
humping on somebody and it's just like
what in the [ __ ]
is this and uh
she goes oh yeah that's why like what is
this bill and i was like oh yeah i kind
of
this did not register with me the first
time
and then i remember this is so crazy how
i i
i actually was able to understand my
wife was because of the great drummer
john theodore
who was talking about drumming and was
talking about voodoo rhythms and was
talking about
how that whole religion was
misrepresented
in a racist way by white people i was
like oh [ __ ]
and i and i remember thinking i need to
read up on that i never did
and then i saw this movie saw my wife's
reaction to it and then i looked it up
and all of this [ __ ] and to this day how
people still think it's like [ __ ]
this you know this crazy
evil [ __ ] thing evidently it was just
an amalgam
of all of a bunch of religions from
africa mixed in with catholicism that
was sort of
forced on him by slave owners
and during u.s reconstruction oh jesus
i'm getting in over my head which was
basically
after the end of the civil war i got it
right here in front of me i'm not trying
to be a scholar here 1865 1877
um during which during which time
attempts were made to redress the
inequities of slavery and its
political social and economic legacy and
to solve the problems arrive
arising from um uh
the readmission of the union also to get
the states
back together so during that time
you know racist white people were
freaking out
about freed black people and then the
power that they were going to have
because of their numbers with voting and
all of this [ __ ]
so that was during the time where they
used
this religion as a way to demonize them
further
um sorry here we go i'll read this real
quick there's nothing like a horror
story to concentrate
and focus our deepest fears as
african-american study scholar
uh michelle y gordon writes that's just
what white newspapers in louisiana did
during reconstruction turning white
supremacists worries about black freedom
into unsettling tales of voodoo
um gordon notes that new orleans did
have real practitioners of voodoo
a synthesis of african religions and
roman catholicism closely linked
to haitian voodoo though the 19th
century
through the 19th century black women
often led its worship and magical
practices but
the supposed eyewitness and secondhand
accounts of voodoo ceremonies
in white papers had little to do with
the that belief system
newspapers promised stories of voodoos
on the rampage
in full particulars of the hell broth
and orgies
an 1870 account in the new orleans daily
something or other described a female
voodoo leader demanding that her
followers
sacrifice animals destroy crops
participate
in sexual orgies and ultimately
participate in a lord's supper
consisting
of her own infant so that's where that
[ __ ] went off the rails now i'm not
saying if you delved into voodoo i'm
sure they got some weird [ __ ]
but so does everybody catholicism this
is my body this is my blood now come on
up and [ __ ] eat it and drink it i
mean it's [ __ ] weird
religion is [ __ ] weird and
um so what they depict
if you watch that movie dude like you
know it's de niro
it's [ __ ] uh mickey rook and all that
[ __ ] but to see that thing and then i
really understood
sitting there became another
embarrassing moment as i'm [ __ ]
watching this going like
oh yeah i guess if i if that information
was given to me i i would have found
this movie
not as good as i thought it was but i
mean listen i'm not coming down on
people because everybody
look i'm not gonna be all these people
that goes back and watch this movie from
35 years ago be like oh my god how come
it's not in 2021 wokeness
i just thought it was amazing you know
really interesting
that my wife saw it when it came out was
like [ __ ] this movie it's [ __ ] stupid
she was a kid when she saw it because
she was informed and all of that [ __ ]
and i was like that was a good movie de
niro playing saint
which that aspect of the movie it was
[ __ ] mickey rook was incredible
the story was great what mickey rourke's
cr uh
character was going through but the
whole
lisa bonnet story was kind of like wow
like what yeah it was it was uh
yeah i got a little uncomfortable there
but um anyway so
next thing i'm going to watch is uh
oh jesus i'm going to watch the one what
was it uh
mickey rourke made a movie called
chinatown now i'm not coming down on
mickey rook either mickey rook is the
[ __ ]
and it's just like this is just like
i guess it's a good thing that you go
back 35 years ago and you watch
something
and you're like oh this uh things have
moved forward like it it should be
okay i'm not trying to be one of these
canceled cultured douchebags here
which i'm you know now i'm feeling bad
that i said all that [ __ ] because i know
somebody's probably gonna uh
[ __ ] take what i just take a clip of
that and then just do their whole stupid
[ __ ] thing
you know acting like they care about
other people and it's just really just
another
white person trying to show how amazing
they are as they pat themselves on the
back pretending to care about others
okay there i said it all right um
but what i was trying to get to was the
comedy of me watching that with my wife
she's [ __ ] dancing with that bloody
chicken
with her [ __ ] titties out i was just
going like
oh yeah forgot about that i just was you
know with de niro with the [ __ ]
long nails and [ __ ] louis cipher
all of that [ __ ] and uh you know it was
kind of like my uh
i see dead people the ending you know
what i mean that was
whatever that movie was called was it
called i see dead people at this point
i don't know i mean can you i don't even
bring up
these other movies that you bring up
that people thought they that were
quaint
and now you kind of watch them now it's
like does this yeah is this guy kind of
making fun of special needs here
all right um anyway but
i will tell you this though i think the
worst time to be an actress
all right an up-and-coming actress was
probably the 70s and 80s
because once nudity became acceptable
the ridiculous level that you could be
as an actress and you still i guess were
required to show your titties was
[ __ ] ridiculous
you know i mean i watched i'm not gonna
name these [ __ ] movies i don't get
people in trouble here but i watch this
[ __ ] movie and one of the actresses
job
her job was basically to be walking
around half naked and stretching
and i got i saw that you didn't even
question it like that's
that's and i get you know what's funny
because i'm such a [ __ ]
sexist meat head actually going back and
watching these movies is helping me with
a lot of the [ __ ] that these hairy leg
chicks are talking about now and i'm
kind of like oh you know i think i
finally i think i'm starting to get this
it's not like i don't get it but you
know i just like being a dick i think
that that's what it is i really start
i think i like being a dick because
people who should have been nice to me
were a dick to me
so then i've i've developed you know
i've developed that pattern oh are you
looking for understanding and empathy
well i'm going to be a [ __ ] [ __ ]
jesus christ you know this [ __ ]
pandemic better end scene a bet and
scene better end soon because if i find
one more ugly layer to my personality i
don't know what i'm going to do here
um all right jesus christ let's get to
the advertising everybody
if i didn't just shut off the recorder
um
all right where are we here hey where
are we where are we
all right here we go all right policy
genius everybody
you know summer did i turn this down
accidentally no tell me i didn't do that
did i no the volume's where it needs to
be
all right summer's quickly approaching
pocket let me start over again
policy genius summer's approaching
quickly
is quickly approaching enjoy it without
a looming to-do list
policy genius makes it easy to get life
insurance done
and done right feeling productive after
submitting your taxes
ride that wave and get insurance
get life insurance done too with policy
genius it's quick and easy
if you have anyone relying on your
income you need
life insurance yeah you should also be
cooking your own food
got to be careful people why policy
genius policy genius makes it easy to
compare quotes from over a dozen top
insurers
all in one place why compare well
you can save fifty percent or more on
life insurance by comparing quotes with
policy genius
you could save thirteen hundred dollars
or more on life insurance by using
policy genius to compare policy
the license experts at policy genius
work for you
not the insurance companies you can
trust them to help you navigate
every step of your of the shopping and
buying process
that kind of service has earned policy
genius a five-star rating across
thousands of reviews on trustpilot and
google
uh getting started is easy first head to
policygenius.com in minutes you can work
out how much life insurance coverage you
need and compare personalized quotes
to find your best price when you're
ready to apply the policy genius team
will handle the paperwork and scheduling
for free
policy genius never sells your
information to other companies policy
genius doesn't add on extra fees
head to policygenius.com get started
right now policy genius when it comes to
insurance
it's nice to get it right oh look who's
here everybody it's simply safe
simply safe is an award-winning home
security system so you know
it's engineered with the latest
technology you want to keep your family
safe but what really sets simply safe
apart
is its people highly trained security
experts who are always there for you
when you need them most
these are people who truly care about
keeping you safe
uh when an alarm goes off a person who
cares is there for you
and a phone call to make sure you're
okay when an emergency happens
a person who cares is there for you like
is a person who's strapped
i already said we're going oh i want
[ __ ] john wayne coming through the
door a person who cares is there
for you by getting fire and police
responders to your front door right away
there we go here come the heroes
even if uh you're just having a problem
setting up your system a person who
cares is there for you with a friendly
chat and a quick
uh resolution the bottom line is when
you need the most simply safe is there
24 7
with people who care and experts train
to not only keep you safe
but to make you feel safe it's one of
the many reasons us news
recently called simply safe the best
home security of 2021
to learn more about how simply safe can
protect you and your family
visit simplysafe.com today to customize
your system and get a free security
camera it's so [ __ ] easy
you get it you can set it up within 30
minutes if i can figure out how to do it
so can you
you also get a 60 day risk free trial so
there's nothing to lose that's
simplysafe.com to customize
your simply safe system and get a free
security camera
s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e
dot com slash bar all right oh look who
it is stamps.com
everybody last one here everybody
stamps.com are you still going to the
post office still paying full price for
postage
well thanks to stamps.com you don't have
to anymore mail and ship
anytime anywhere right from your
computer send letters ship packages and
pay less a lot less with discounted
rates from us
postal service and ups and more you've
heard me talk about stamps.com they've
been sponsoring the show for over nine
years now thank you so much to them
and if you haven't tried it what are you
waiting for stamps.com brings the
services of the us postal service and
ups right to your computer
it's a must-have for any business i ship
out all my merch i don't do a lot of
merch but i'm gonna be selling my uh my
my vinyl album on my upcoming tour and i
will be using stamps.com it's so simple
so easy
uh whether you're a small office sending
invoices a side hustle
etsy shop shipping out orders or just
navigating this hybrid work life
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
no wonder over 1 million businesses
choose stamps.com for their mailing and
shipping
simply use any your computer to print
official us postage 24 7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it
once your mail mail is ready just
schedule a pick up or drop it off it's
that simple
with stamps.com you get discounts of up
to 40
off post office rates and up to 66
percent off u.s
ups shipping rates not to mention
stamps.com is a fraction of the cost of
those
expensive postage meters stamps.com is a
no-brainer
saving you time and money it's no wonder
nearly 1 million small businesses
already use stamps.com stop wasting time
going to the post office and go to
stamps.com instead
there's no risk and with the promo code
bur burr
you get a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus free postage and a
digital scale no long term commitments
or contracts just go to stamps.com click
on the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in burr.stamps.com
promo codeburr stamps.com
never go to the post office again all
right
you know i realize the secret of reading
out loud is is to slow the [ __ ] down
the [ __ ] can we start going through god
damn fast slow it
down bill uh
oh jesus christ you know something i
[ __ ] can't stand people you know i'm
all excited
i'm all excited about getting a ford
f250
right so what does some [ __ ] do he
goes out
is what he says ford's super death
wobble
hey billy tonka tits you should be aware
of this ford
death wobble and get a cyber truck
instead of that dumb donkey cart
this [ __ ] [ __ ] goes out and just
[ __ ] googles people dying in ford's
like you can't do that in every other
[ __ ] truck
jesus christ remember that [ __ ] that
that guy with the t-shirt company that
actor died in a ferrari
do people tell me not to [ __ ] you
know go on set and
drive a ferrari [ __ ] happens
all right let's see here open the link
here we go this guy just killing my
dream
bill's excited about it uh the truck in
the foreground was trailed
to a work site today for a photo shoot
the f-150 truck in the background was
driven to a site
to help build translation ford
executives have scared shitless about
having real competition for the first
time
since the chicken tax i don't know what
this means
okay the truck in the background driving
to the job site
what am i looking at something went
wrong with this no did ford shut it down
uh meanwhile the bad news continues for
tesla compared to the competition
falling behind here's a bad one about
tesla dude go [ __ ] yourself all right
this is the truck i want i know
inherently everything is dangerous
okay i accept the risk
god you know some that's actually i'm
glad you wrote that in that that is a
great that is a great uh
life lesson that when you say out loud
that you want to do something and you're
excited about it
uh people immediately try to bring you
negative information
so you don't go out and do it and be
happy now they'll paint themselves as
heroes like hey
i was just looking out for you the [ __ ]
out of here
you know did you look at it look up
anything else yeah ford's have had
problems
every [ __ ] car is out every car every
car company has had recalls all right
as long as the gas tank isn't like the
way it was on the [ __ ] pinto
or the the crown vic i'm good i'm good i
drive
like a [ __ ] old man there's gonna be
no
death wobble as i go down the street
with a [ __ ]
dopamine grin on my face when i get that
[ __ ] truck
and the color that i want sir can i can
i just
can i have this can you just let me have
this
all right gen zer oh generation z let's
look this up let's see where the
generation z people fit it
nice to hear from a gen z person gen z
years okay i like this understanding gen
ye's
z people how the [ __ ] are you gonna do
that all right uh they are currently
between
age uh 6 and 24 years old
nearly 68 million in the u.s okay
well welcome uh i'm a gen zier and i
want to to bring a little first-hand
experience to the podcast you've said
that the generation
after the millennials is much cooler and
i'm sorry to tell you we are not
oh no the same division and extreme
opinions on everything is plaguing my
generation
don't you think a lot of it though is
the [ __ ] internet and a lot of it is
the um 24-hour news networks considering
you know covet affected everybody and we
we just could not get on the same page
and i'm not even talking about the left
and the right
there's there was subsets within the
left
subsets within the right subsets within
the subsets it was just crazy
anyways he said a friend of mine got
kicked out of public high school
for calling his locker [ __ ]
a girl nearby heard him and said he
called her a [ __ ] and made some
inflammatory hand signals
for some context he is the only broken
locker in the hallway
and the lock doesn't work so his books
have been stolen because of it
um well yeah that's terrible
but i mean didn't you guys learn all of
this from older generations
i just hate how everybody's ratting
everybody out now
and acting like it's i guess it's like
there's feeling of power
i mean i can tell if look if this [ __ ]
went down the way this went down like
you know she shouldn't have done that
but she's also you know in high school
her brain's still developing
she's on social media and all this [ __ ]
i just don't think it's good
i have empathy for you guys um we're not
allowed to listen to music on school
grounds because one student complained
that the only music
they hear on campus campus promotes
american exceptionalism
oh brother what they couldn't say
rap music or trap music because it would
point out that predominantly black music
was the problem
so they did it under the guise of
american exceptionalism
jesus these racists are getting [ __ ]
educated that sounds like a lawyer
american exceptionalism don't we kind of
have to have that the way everybody's
been [ __ ] on us around the world
i mean we got to do something everybody
just thinks we're fat and dumb walking
around with a gun
riding a four-wheeler with your dick out
um not to say you ain't allowed to do
that
uh we're not allowed to use any hand
gestures during sports thumbs up thumbs
down
doesn't matter all are considered too
dangerously close to white supremacist
symbols well that's not your generation
that's just corporate lawyers
trying to uh you know a lot of it
becomes
corporate lawyers trying to head off
everything at the pass
and uh you know it's it's all money
driven that's the funny thing about all
this [ __ ] most of these all of this
decisions
like them kicking that kid out of school
with the locker comment
it has nothing to do with that girl's
feelings it has to do with
they have to do the right thing so they
don't get sued
anyways she's this person says uh he or
she says
i as an asian american was told that i
was not allowed to answer more than one
question in class
per day because i was making other honor
students feel uncomfortable
with my aggressive level of
competitiveness
wow the teacher has enforced this with
me
but has allowed the honor student and
others to answer multiple questions
oh because you're asian and they just
think you're going to be smarter than
everybody that's so [ __ ]
weird note i never raised my hand more
than once or twice a class and usually
it was because no one else would i wish
you were right but my experience tells a
different story thanks and go [ __ ]
yourself
well first of all the only thing that
made me happy and all of that
all of those examples were that you
actually said go [ __ ] yourself so they
haven't killed you off
spiritually um listen
you're in controlled environments but i
don't think that that
you know needs to affect
your everyday life or whatever when you
guys go to hang out or whatever i would
try to just
open dialogues than what other kids tell
on you oh my god it's just become this
whole [ __ ] red scare everywhere you
go it's just people telling on other
people
i can tell you this how i've reacted to
all of this [ __ ] is i just
continued to uh you know
i know i don't try to improve as a
person i am trying but like
you know i know the intent of what it is
that i'm saying
i'm not being malicious i'm not saying i
can't make a mistake and i can't [ __ ]
cross a line here or there
but if i do you know i'll own up to it
i'll apologize
but like this whole [ __ ] thing you
crossed the line and now you should be
just eliminated
is uh that is the perverted
sort of like hardcore white chick
[ __ ] thing where they're not really
going down for this cause as much as
they are is trying to remove
white guys that are in the way so that
they can then
be the toxic person running [ __ ]
um which is my prediction of what's
going to happen is that they're going to
remove
all of these people and it's going to be
like we're going to have diversity
and you know what that means it means
it's there's gonna be a bunch of white
chicks getting all the
the good [ __ ] first and then whatever
leftover they're gonna give to people of
color
and then it's gonna take a long while
before it slowly turns before you're
able to
to really constructively go aren't they
doing what white males did
but they just have a vagina so nobody
could say anything
i think there'll be a little bit of that
that's my prediction what do i know
all right boyfriend doesn't want to get
married
he doesn't want to get married hey
billford i love the podcast thanks for
being yourself i was hoping to get some
dating advice all right well
i'm a [ __ ] up dude so take everything
i say with the grain of salt
uh my boyfriend and i have been dating
for two years and living together for a
year and a half i'm 31 and he's 38 we
both
have education's a good job he doesn't
want to get married he's 38 yeah you got
to kick him to the curb
he ain't going to get there um he's a
great guy he's not going to get there in
a time where you still have
like if you want to have kids i would
guess that's my
first that's the first thought i had
he's a great guy he's very sweet
respectful and makes me laugh
his family is lovely as well he's a
musician and loves music as much as i do
i love our life together as it is but
it's our future i'm worried about
i want to get married and have a kid or
two he's indecisive about it
he's an indecisive person in general
i've dropped some heavy hints and
frequently talk about a hypothetical
future
when we have kids and we're married but
he's just not into it
yeah he's not into it or he's afraid of
it the way i was
but i can tell you like it's it's added
to my stand-up and all the creative
things that i do
having kids so maybe you can tell them
that
um because i know with a lot of people
in this business trying to make it you
try to travel
light because you feel like i got to get
to this certain place and then i can
actually have a life
and you think you're getting to that
place is actually going to bring you
happiness when what
really could bring you happiness is just
finding love
you know and having a couple of kids and
trying to make sure that they have the
best possible childhood
will fill you up so much more than all
of that other dumb [ __ ]
which took me half a century to fill up
figure out um
anyway uh i've tried to be being extra
sweet cooking all his favorite meals
every night making sure the house is
always clean
and babying him when he gets sick i'm
even supportive of his dream of quitting
his good job
to be a writer and a musician however
all my efforts don't seem to be working
because he is still
isn't willing to compromise on the
marriage and kids thing it makes me
really sad especially the kid
part it worries me because well biology
i'm already 31 and i can't be waiting
forever
my family and friends say i should give
him an ultimatum but i don't want to
because one
what if he calls my bluff i love him and
i really want to spend the rest of my
life with him too
i have pride self-esteem and self-worth
even though i'm not
exactly god's gift to mankind are you
talking about you're a great person a
great person
i'm not a piece of [ __ ] either and
shouldn't have to threaten a man to
marry me
am i doing something wrong am i being
nutty or do i need to move on
[ __ ] you and thanks um
i don't think you're nutty at all i
think you don't have to put pressure on
just say what you just said to me
just say you not you being unwilling to
compromise
about getting married and having kids
makes me really spare
sad especially the kid part you know
i don't have all the time this is what i
want and i want to do it with you
okay and i don't want to give you an
ultimatum all right i just want you to
be honest with me
okay and then tell them listen this is
when i want to do this by
which also gives him another way to
[ __ ] string you along
and i would just say listen it's going
to break my heart to leave you but i am
not going to be
childless that's not what i want that's
not going to make me happy
i want to get married and start a family
with you do you want to do that with me
okay and i have to be honest with you
his answer
is if it's yes would be right then and
there if he's like
you know just i would leave
leave and go through the [ __ ]
heartbreak of that [ __ ]
rather than live a whole life of
wondering what could have been
all right that's my advice to you and
never feel bad for expressing your
feelings and and you don't have to
give ultimatums to people you just tell
them how you're feeling
how what they're doing is making you
feel and they're either receptive to it
or they're not if they're not receptive
to it
you know you got to get to someone who's
going to be receptive or that's going to
be your
day-to-day existence which is going to
drive you into depression
all right and if they want what you want
the cart moves forward if it doesn't
hey you know no hard feelings this kills
me to do this but like you know i want
what i want and what you want
is just as important as what he wants so
that's the deal
you get with somebody you gotta want
basically the same [ __ ] or it's not
gonna work
all right sorry you're going through
that good luck to you
all right groomsman become a groom's
woman groom's man be became a groom's
woman
hey billary swank i'm getting married
this summer to my beautiful girlfriend
of eight years we're having a family
small
wedding so i was planning on inviting my
three best friends from high school
to be my groomsmen one of my friends
anna came out as trans over a year ago
and we all support and respect her
decisions
i invited her to in january to be one of
my groom's people
along with my other two guy friends all
right so what's the problem
however just this past week one of my
guys friends also came out as trans what
the [ __ ]
it plans to be transitioning from male
to female
now my groomsmen went from being one
woman
and two guys to two women and just one
guy i was already stepping out of my
comfort zone by inviting anna
to be a groom's person and now i feel
like i can't uninvite the other guy
because i already told anna she could
join
yeah and this is another thing too this
is something that you would really get
trashed for for being like
transphobic and all that you're just
being honest
okay these are two people that you knew
as guys who are no longer guys and now
you have to emotionally deal with it
there's nothing wrong with that you're
not saying what they're doing is wrong
you're just saying it makes you
uncomfortable for some reason you can't
say that now
or you can say it and everybody gets all
your [ __ ] homophobic
um anyway it's it's less about or
transphobic
it's less about them being trans and
more about just me not wanting to be
surrounded by women during the ceremony
i'm pretty i'm a pretty traditional guy
despite my friends and i've always
imagined the classic group of groomsmen
at my side for my wedding
also not to mention tim just recently
started transitioning as 6'3
it might look a little out of place in a
dress
all right you walk in the line just
invites just you know expand your draft
picks
pay for a couple more meals get some
more [ __ ] swinging dicks in there you
got some dresses i think you got a nice
salad going on there
uh i love my friends but i just don't
want to be the focus to be about them on
our wedding
i asked the person if they'd feel
comfortable in a suit for the ceremony
they said
probably but may change their mind
closer to the wedding
is it wrong for me to put my foot down
and just say they need to wear a suit or
step out of the groomsmen party
any advice would be greatly appreciated
and also go [ __ ] yourself well you know
this is one of these things where a
wedding is her day
and what you're doing right now is
really bride behavior
like you're picking the colors you want
to know how they dress and i don't know
if we're really going to be progressive
if the woman can do that can't the guy
do that
um this is what i say you do i say
that you know
you you have the wedding that you want
to have because it is your
it is your wedding and the way you want
to have it is the way that you want to
have it and you know
you don't seem like you have a problem
with what these guys are doing
and now that are now women the days
whatever the [ __ ] you're supposed to say
so i would just try to have the wedding
that you want to say everybody's still
[ __ ] invited
not the way you want to say the wedding
that you want to have and then just
just take it from there i mean
personally
uh
i'm trying to think i i don't know i
don't know that
i haven't been through what you've been
through like if i had like two of my
close friends that i was growing up with
all of a sudden
were transitioning i mean that's that's
a [ __ ] major thing
um i would think emotionally to deal
with because it's like the other person
doesn't exist anymore
you know so you got to kind of take time
to process that which is something i
think is missing in all of that
because i really think you know you
should support somebody if that's what
they want to do
and still be friends with them and all
that type of [ __ ] and then i think
conversely they should give you a second
you know to be like okay let me uh let
me get my head around this thing you
know so
yeah i i but i think in the end dude
this is this is your wedding
this is your wedding and you should have
your wedding the way you want it
to be in the way that you want it to
look and everything and i think if
you're still going to be friends with
them and all of that [ __ ]
and you're not being going oh my god
that's against god and all that dumb
[ __ ]
uh i think this is a small ass to be can
you just wear a suit i don't think
that's a big [ __ ] deal
i really don't or maybe
you slide them over to the other side
they become bridesmaids
and you know with any luck two of the
chicks transition over your side you
know what i mean it's like a [ __ ] nfl
trade
two for two all right girlfriend wants
me to move out
dear billy long nuts
is that an age joke if that's an age
joke that's [ __ ] hilarious
uh i'm a 21 year old college student
um that billy longnuts is [ __ ]
if that's because you're old and your
balls are hanging down low that is
[ __ ] hilarious
um is that my native american name
him billy long nuts um all right i'm a
21 year old college student and my
girlfriend and i have been arguing a lot
because she wants me to move out of my
parents house
into a house share so that we can be
closer
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
i'm a 21-year-old caution my girlfriend
and i have been arguing a lot because
she wants me to move out of my parents
house
oh i thought she meant she wanted you
her to move out
you guys were living again and she
wanted you to move on i was like all
right
you're 21. this is some of the great
greatest news you could ever get
all right she wants me to move out of my
parents house into a house share so that
we can be closer
we currently live 40 minutes from each
other
she makes ominous statements about the
practical
practicality of our relationship and if
i don't move and catch
and and catches an attitude because
of it every time we meet up or talk on
the phone it's getting exhausting and i
feel a lot of pressure from her
constantly bringing it up all right and
how does that make you feel
do you like feeling pressured do you
like somebody giving you an attitude
because you're doing what it is that you
want to do rather than what
she wants you to do buddy this is the
tip of the iceberg
and and this is this thing that
manipulative people do
is she's going to make it seem like
that when you move in with her that this
pressure and all of this [ __ ] is gonna
end and you're gonna be happy you'll be
happy for week ten days
and then she's gonna start with this
[ __ ] again you are laying the groundwork
for this relationship where she's gonna
get to use
her emotions as as like this this
this manipulative tool to get you
to [ __ ] sit up beg go for a walk take
out the trash and do all of this [ __ ]
i can tell you right now dude do not i
don't even need to read the rest of it
don't even [ __ ] move
anyway she's moving out of home uh
to live in her grand dude did you voice
texas
i'm gonna write i'm gonna read just how
you wrote it she is moving out of her
home to live in her grandmother
who passed away's house in the city
so she won't be paying rent okay so her
grandmother died and she wants you to
move in there because it's her family
home
she doesn't want me to stay over or for
us to have sex
there sir did you really
need you really need my advice here i
respect this boundary
this however sucks as it means that the
decision for us to have
a sex life and private time together
rests in my hands
yeah dude she's she's she's [ __ ]
she's boxing you in
i really want to move out but it would
cost me about 600
a month plus bills and food and i'm not
sure i can afford it i have explained
this to her but she says that
her paying bills in her grandmother's
house makes us even
i'll be honest with you i [ __ ] hate
this chick i'm just being honest
i also have an unplayed work placement
abroad next year which i need to save
for
that will cost me three to four thousand
dollars there you go buddy
that's the carrot on the stick you need
to be be
chasing my parents do not and will not
financially support me
i really love this girl and despite the
obstacles of not having privacy and the
distance between us our relationship has
been great up until this point
i'm starting to wonder if it'll work out
what do you think i should do
um i think you should stay at home and
save up that three to four grand and she
should understand that
i think you should tell her how her
pressuring you makes you feel
and if she doesn't acknowledge this and
doesn't care about your feelings and
it's all about her
it's the tip of the [ __ ] iceberg and
consider yourself lucky
that you're not living with her when you
break up with her that's it
um if i learned anything in the last few
months of therapy
it's just like you know i have not
acknowledged my feelings and my feelings
were not acknowledged
my entire time growing up which is why
i'm an angry person
because when i start to feel feelings
that i don't like in my head i just have
to go to anger because i never thought i
could just be like
hey man i really don't like that because
i grew up in the sit down and shut the
[ __ ] up
generation so
none of this makes you feel good so you
need to tell that to her and there's no
[ __ ] way you move in with this chick
ever
under these circumstances where she is
basically
[ __ ] uh uh using her emotions to get
you to do what she wants to do and then
having a [ __ ] attitude
i mean do you realize like seriously if
i can just take a second here
like that childish behavior that so many
women get away with
with the guys in their relationship that
you basically have to dance to their
[ __ ] tune
or they won't be happy because then what
ends up happening
is your happiness has to exist within
the circle of their happiness and at
that point you're no longer
an individual you've lost yourself in
the relationship
you've become like like this emotional
[ __ ] hostage
and it's [ __ ] [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] all right so sorry i'm [ __ ]
got gas here i know i think i wolf down
this [ __ ] piece of toast before this
i apologize um
belching up a storm here um yeah so [ __ ]
that
and any person male or female listening
to this don't ever
move in with somebody if if that
is the way it's going down don't ever
get involved
in a business or a personal intimate
relationship
where the other person is using their
[ __ ] moods as a way
to get you to do something that you do
not want to do
but they wear you out because you just
want to see them happy hey
[ __ ] their happiness their happiness is
not your responsibility your happiness
is your responsibility and you don't
[ __ ] move in with somebody until
their happiness and your happiness
intersect that's it go [ __ ] yourselves
i'll talk to you on thursday